I'm not really a big fan of jean-luc
godard anymore I think I'm not trying to
be disrespectful I just think I've
outgrown him Kjar was so influential to
me at the beginning of my aesthetic as a
director of like wanting to be a
director it's kind of like lack of
complete any type of film style just
just wanting to make movies for love
oven guitar is the one who taught me the
fun and the freedom and the joy of
breaking rules just [ __ ] around with
the entire medium like many other things
in our modern world the course of film
history was changed forever by the
second world war the despite having
grown out of him Quentin Tarantino's
self-conscious postmodern aesthetic is a
direct descendant of the self-conscious
postmodern work of jean-luc Godard and
the French New Wave of which Godard
is a pioneer emerges and is a response
to the circumstances arising out of the
end of World War two let me explain a
year after the end of the war after the
liberation of France from Nazi control
French Prime Minister Leon blue traveled
to Washington DC to meet with Secretary
of State James burns to negotiate an
agreement that would cancel France's two
billion dollar war debt the result of
the bloom Byrnes agreement was the
almost complete opening of French
markets to American cultural products
particularly films before this Agreement
France had imposed quotas on the number
of American films allowed to play in
French theaters as a way to preserve the
unique identity of French cinema the
bloom burns agreement decimated those
quotas resulting in the free market
domination of American Hollywood movies
in France into this universe the
founding members of the French new-wave
grew up in the pages of Calle du Cinema
they advanced a new form of film theory
criticizing many of their French
forefathers and praising the work of
Hollywood studio directors like Alfred
Hitchcock Orson Welles and John for LA
Dodger finished the job awash in
hundreds of Hollywood movies and
in-depth analysis of American authors
Luc Godard makes breathless from a story
treatment by NuWave compatriots Francois
Truffaut and Claude roll breathless is
an extended investigation of a French
filmic identity in the shadow of
Hollywood dominance of indeed whether an
identity informed by another nation's
culture can exist at all breathless
tells the story of small-time crook
Michel in the aftermath of his murder of
a police officer on his way to see his
American lover Patricia in Paris Michele
models his personality on Humphrey
Bogart just as the film models itself on
a Hollywood crime thriller but in both
cases these identifications are
continually frustrated for example take
a look at the film's inciting incident
the film opens with Michel dressed like
a parody of an American gangster
mimicking a gesture attributed to Bogart
he then steals an American oldsmobile
from an American military officer which
almost immediately furnishes him with an
implement to make his identity complete
a revolver after running a light
Michelle is chased by two motorcycle
cops one eventually tracks him down and
a shootout ensues the classic dramatic
moment of the film noir but look at the
sequence of shots in which this shootout
unfolds nebbish paused to bleed
the whole scene plays like a misfire of
these kinds of moments not only does a
murder seem totally unmotivated for the
crime committed but we don't even get to
see the cops face the shootout takes
place over only five shots in 10 seconds
with imagery and sound effects out of
sync and the camera impulsively favors
extreme close-ups that obscure the
action instead of wide shots that would
have made everything clear everything in
the sequence serves to rob Michel of his
part in the confrontation the film
itself intervenes to strip the scene
down to bare formulaic elements in this
way the film is always watching over me
shell making comments on his immature
desire to become Bogart or actually
interjecting itself to upset that desire
later Michele confronts a poster of his
hero a giant image of Bogart from his
very last movie - harder they fall
you can see Michele's pale reflection
being dwarfed by his hero and then you
have a face-off between the two men both
totally stone-faced and unreadable
seconds later the film loudly announces
itself by ending the scene with a wacky
awkward outmoded
iris transition what's being called -
attention here well I think the late
film critic Dennis Turner gives us a
hint when he cites the French
psychoanalyst Jacques Lacan cela Khan's
most famous contribution to our
understanding of human development is
something called the mirror stage it
describes the moment when a baby first
sees itself in the mirror is that little
Vera is that you too young to have any
control yet over itself the infant
recognizes a unity in its mirror version
and aspires to that unity projecting
itself into the place of the other this
means that the very formation of
ourselves the first time we perceive
ourselves as a subject what we perceive
is not really us it's an imaginary
projection of us for this reason the
human subject says Lacan is always
divided it's never really hope Michel is
someone
assumed by his identification looking at
Bogart he doesn't recognize the
impossibility of becoming his hero he
just stares intently forward and it's
left to the film and it's anachronistic
fade-out to inform us that it knows
better Michels immaturity is matched by
his love interests Patricia that long
famous scene that sits at the heart of
this movie with Michelle holed up in
Patricia's bedroom is preceded by a long
look in the mirror by Patricia
and it features mirrors all the way
through and images of lovers and other
men and women both characters are lost
in search of a solid identity that might
be reflected in the other there back and
forth is a constant oblique probing into
the other hoping to mine some reaction
some statement that might explain
finally they are from over feed on
Brashear yeah that's good I'm gonna push
more from Camille again at the end of
the film Michelle finally gets
everything he needs to escape but after
Patricia betrays him to the police his
imaginary identification with Bogart is
finally broken the tragedy is that the
film still forces him along the tracks
of the genre inside which he's trapped
the cops bumbling like silly parodies of
themselves all throughout the film still
nonetheless gunned him down breathless
like its hero oscillates between these
two registers it wants to participate in
the Hollywood filmmaking it admires but
it knows that such an identification is
impossible so it deals with this by
being self-conscious by using jump cuts
awkward transitions by robbing the
classic moments of their force or making
the heroes bloody final steps way longer
than it could ever possibly be forcing
you outside of the film's text or back
into it again depending on how you look
at it it's no surprise that the effects
of war are vast and unexpected America
flooded France with its films onto which
the new way filmmakers projected a
superiority that they created by then
identifying with it in their movies in
other words American economic dominance
created an ideological dominance in the
minds of the dominated for Godard the
only way to deal with this was to be
conscious of the dynamic unfixed nature
of these identities indeed it's the only
way that we can deal with the dynamic
unfix nature of our own identities
the unexpected thing is how influential
that consciousness was when it
eventually came back across the hunt hey
everybody thanks for watching the first
set of nerdwriter stickers have been
sent out in the mail so you got some of
those on patreon check for that also
there are a lot more stickers than I
thought so I'm going to put up 60 more
sets of those stickers on my patreon
page which you can claim by clicking
right here pledging three dollars per
video and you get two stickers you've
already got the reward I'd asked you to
keep pledging just because you know
that's what makes this channel possible
my patreon you know these videos take
like 50 hours to make so it is a
full-time job you know legitimately and
I hope you guys see that reflected in
the quality of the content so thank you
guys so much again and I will see you
all next Wednesday